- Millie, we just re-hydrated the brisket.
- Mm-hm.
- We left it on for
about 10 or 15 minutes,
which kind of surprised me, but it's like,
that's what's gonna do it.
Give it the time, invest in it.
And now what are we doing?
- So we're gonna take our
leftover macaroni and cheese.
I mean, oftentimes,
there's never any leftover
macaroni and cheese.
- Not with me.
- But in this instance
we have little bit left over.
So what we'll do is we
have some sliced pieces,
they're already cold
and we're gonna put some
into our waffle iron.
- Oh, so you like, you chill it.
- You chill it.
So this is like, when
you have it leftover,
you take it out the casserole dish.
- Oh God.
- So we're gonna add one piece of macaroni
on the bottom.
- Only one's fitting in here.
- [Millie] Then we're gonna
put some cheese in the middle.
- [Drew] Oh, okay, more cheese, sure.
- And then we'll take
another piece of the waffle
and I mean the waffle,
the macaroni and cheese
and we're gonna put it on top.
- Oh another?
Okay, great.
- We're gonna create like
a little sandwich.
- Oh.
I mean, yes please.
- And be careful.
That's really hot.
- Yes.
- And then as it melts down
it'll close some more.
(audience applauds)
And this is what it looks like.
- Oh my God.
- Gooey, nice and cheesy.
And then we have our brisket.
So we're just gonna put some on top.
- Look at this, you guys.
Look at this.
- I'm gonna put some on top
and you put as little or
as much as you like on top.
Then I have some scallions.
I love a good green onion.
- I love a chive,
a scallion, a shallot, an onion, a garlic.
- Leek.
- A leek!
(Drew screams excitedly)
- Yes. Ma'am.
- I just made this like leek
based soup the other day.
And it was, Oh, it was so good.
- I like all types of onions.
- I'm going big here, Millie
and I can see the onions,
which I really like, they're...
- And you saw how we caramelized them
so they got a little sweeter.
So there is like a good, balanced dish.
And then here I have it with
some, another repurposed dish.
This is my New York Times mango slaw.
And you can use leftover fruit
that you have in your refrigerator.
I have some cabbage,
some carrots in there.
If you have some collard
greens that are leftover,
short 'em up, put them in there.
This is a wonderful counterbalance
to all of this savory,
cheesy, gooey deliciousness
we have going on.
(audience applauds)
Well, let's just taste
this, how about we do that?
- It's just...
(audience laughs)
You know what, okay.
Now...
- You wanna focus on
getting the plate so clean.
You gotta eat it, don't make it cold now.
- I might start licking it.
I don't know.
All right, now it's...
- [Millie] Gorgeous.
- Okay, here it is, here's my,
my plate that I worked so hard on.
(audience applauds)
- Gorgeous.
- And now, I'm gonna rip into it.
- [Millie] This is good.
- Grr, Millie.
I love that I asked you for a second date.
I literally was like,
"Hi, nice to meet you.
Can we do this again?"
- Mm-hm.
See how good that is.
(audience cheers)
- That little hit of the green,
the parsley and the onion.
It really gives it that brightness-
- Yes.
- and that kick of freshness.
- Come on, chef Drew,
You see her "freshness", "brightness",
all of the chef terms.
I love it.
Look, you, you just savoring
all the moment right now.
It's just so delicious,
you just wanna get into it.
- I am a Cookbook Club person.
I collect cookbooks.
So I wanted to start a club.
And also, I've learned to
cook through watching shows.
- [Millie] Mm-hm.
- And so these shows are very
meaningful and important.
They're educating all of us.
- Right.
- And turning us into
more active chefs at home,
rather than being insecure,
'cause you don't have formal
training or any training.
(audience cheers)
- And you don't need any.
And that's the beauty of it.
Like I'm not formally trained.
These are just recipes
that I've cultivated.
These are recipes that I've made my own.
And that's what I hope,
that Chef's Guide To Soul Food
and all the wonderful workshops
on the Magnolia Network,
teaches each and every person,
whether it's, you know,
Hilton Carter with the plants
and you know, wonderful bakers
like Elise Smith and Sam.
- I'm gonna become a
propagator because Joanna,
Jo,
- Jo.
Hey, boo.
- Has turned me on to
the world of propagating plants.
- Mm-hm?
- I mean, I get so much.
Yesterday I was drooling
over her Fettuccine Alfredo.
Like, I'm a Magnolia
girl through and through
and they are better off for having you-
- Oh thank you.
- On their network.
(audience applauds)
- And we wanna thank them
for all these wonderful
opportunities, thank you.
- Millie Peartree, go to
thedrewbarrymoreshow.com,
follow the full recipe
and watch Millie's
Magnolia workshop series,
A Chef's Guide To Soul Food,
exclusively on the one and only Magnolia.
(bright music)